portugal terre de couleurs chaudes
vivantes ici touvier surtout
l'architecturé jéronimos bâti sur le
quai même du tage en plein style manuel
dentelles de pierre qui prend toute sa
grâce et toute sa raison d'être
en s'élevant vers le ciel
cloud apps
deux étages auquel la pierre de laval et
d'alcantara donne un ton rose doré
action de grâce qu'il a pour unique aux
points c'est beaucoup
quoi
ici emblème des voiles de vasco de gamme
lisbonne
lisbonne et sa maison aux pierres pointu
demeure de la famille d'alphonse
d'albuquerque premier vice roi des indes
lassé cathédrale pierre traîneau tout un
passé antoine de lisbonne il fut baptisé
est servi la messe et puis tout autour
semblant être gardés par la cathédrale
les maisons pittoresques de forme et
vibrant de couleurs
et maintenant regardez regardez bien ici
est le berceau du fado imbroglio
d'architecturé quartier des familles de
marins
là
et surplombant la ville vieux de dix
siècles sans gorgue et ses remparts
servent de promenade au public
et à cela qu'ils ont d'autres
préoccupations
corner le paysage et vivre ainsi bête
printemps
et la ville bâtie comme rome sur cette
colline elle elle a souhaité que c'est
toi descendent jusqu'aux otages n'est
dieu l'ont exaucé
où
à
et chacun accomplissant son travail se
taillent millénaire portes de lourdes
hugo l'est pour qu'elle puisse l
accomplir le leur parfois agités
mais toujours apaisée au soir lorsque
ses amis les pêcheurs rentrent il est
heureux de porter leur barque au flanc
gonflé de poisson
aussi et du côté pratique surtout voies
de communication
voici un rouage joseph premier à la
place même de cette statue eu lieu un
terrible tremblement de terre et un
raz-de-marée qui en un clin d'oeil
ravages à lisbonne
azul et genre petite place semblable en
elle-même à ce qu'elles furent avant le
séisme du xvième siècle et celle du
commerce et son portique dans le présent
ou julie temps aux portes de la ville
belem à manuel on aime on aime ou pas on
la salue toujours car d'ici partie à la
caravelle la conquête des mères et des
pères
non
mais
il
et autres témoignages du passé des
cloîtres celui d'arabie da fondée au 16e
siècle qui depuis regarde la mer face à
face son chemin de croix lui cet âge et
grimpe dans les collines gantés de gris
l'élégant chêne-liège richesse des
provinces de la landaise de l'algarve
moulin et là comme dans les ruelles de
lisbonne le fado éclate et joue son rôle
non
on
scène de la vie fameuse lavandières
non
et sintra au nord de lisbonne ancienne
résidence d'été des rois bâti en quatre
siècles
il a des aspects arables gothique manuel
un héros naissance et tout cela avec
élégance
une vraie gageure
la chambre de la reine ou plutôt son
balcon d'où l'on découvre la campagne et
des ruines celle d'une ancienne
forteresse mauresque et puis alcoba ce
qui nous rappelle don pedro souvenez
vous l'homme un don t indomptables qui
fit couronné dans la mort celle qui
l'aima dans la vie inès de castro et que
son père lui interdisait d'épousé
on
ils bataillent sur monastère logé par
jean premier est offert en cadeau à la
vierge après avoir gagné la bataille
d'alger barotte style gothique
flamboyant
non
nous
gisant à la devise courageuse loyauté je
servirai tant que je serais tu peux dire
mieux et fatima la la vierge est apparue
à trois bergers du pays et depuis le
monde entier vient d'en pèlerinage
saluer se muera les portugais et les
portugais ne traverse le pays à pied
emportant sur leur tête
l'indispensable nourriture
et c'est le plus souvent à jour que ces
femmes pieuses achève ce pèlerinage
celle ci un à côté de son compagnon de
but qui semble la protéger elle ira
jusqu'au pied de cette croix donnant des
rations lieu il fasse que la sienne soit
moins lourde
hélène chagnaud vous a proposé ouayach
un passeport cette émission a été
réalisée avec le concours de solange
péters montage pierre michel rey sont
jean paul tic emploi script nathalie de
muret illustration sonore denise laser